the city of castle in the German state
of Heston has hosted the documenter art
exhibition since its inception in 1955
but this year castle will share that
honor with a city located almost 3,000
kilometers away athens in april the huge
art show will kick off in greece the
first time ever it's opened outside of
Germany documentas artistic director
Adams Tim chicks controversial decision
is a show of solidarity with the city
bearing the brunt of both the economic
crisis and the refugee crisis documenta
is once again coming in for criticism
some say it's view of art is to cerebral
with too many works tackling political
themes at the expense of true artistic
sensibility Nadia Akira pelu a curator
in Athens independent art scene is just
a little nervous about whether Athens
can put it off my biggest concern is
that believe it or not that documenta
will fail we may be critical with it but
we are curious and we wanted to succeed
because we will be left with the post
coitus melancholia architect and
documentary artist Andreas and Gary
darkest says Athens is already the
winner only the most important capital
that documenta is donating to Athens is
is attention because that is something
that you you know you are here making a
documentary other institutions are
interested in doing something in Athens
because documenta is there they want to
share that attention and of course they
generate more so I think that's very
valuable backing Castle another artist
is also directing attention towards
athens Marta minhwan from Argentina will
create a replica of the Parthenon from
100,000 banned books the work is a
protest against the censorship of free
speech